ja dies zur einstimmung auf die heutige
debatte im foyer des bundestages ist
mein kollege erhard scherfer er hat
guten morgen was erwartet uns heute im
deutschen bundestag
alfred schier tag 3 der haushaltswoche
heute und es geht unter anderem um die
etats für die ministerien wirtschaft und
klimaschutz es geht um ernährung und
landwirtschaft und um das thema
gesundheit also drei themen die zu den
großen themen in diesen tagen zählen und
zu den großen herausforderungen beginnen
wird aber die heutige der heutige tag
der haushaltswoche mit dem etat des
bundesinnenministeriums das hätte vor
drei vier fünf jahren noch ganz anders
im fokus und im mittelpunkt gestanden
und das aus nachvollziehbaren gründen
denn heute auf den tag genau vor drei
jahren ist der kasseler
regierungspräsident walter lübcke
erschossen worden von einem täter mit
inzwischen auch verurteilt und deshalb
kann man es auch so sagen mut
rechtsextremen völkischen nationalen
motiven das ganze und insgesamt muss man
sagen hat sich die lage in diesem feld
im bereich der politisch motivierten
straftaten
nicht verbessert im gegenteil im
vergangenen jahr war die anzahl solcher
straftaten so hoch wie nie auch die
anzahl der gewalttaten ist deutlich nach
oben gegangen und
rechtsextremistisch motivierte taten
ebenso wie judenfeindliche also
insgesamt keine besonders gute
ausgangslage aber im mittelpunkt in
diesen tagen stehen vor allem andere
bereiche nämlich die digitale welt mit
chat und messenger diensten und deren
möglichkeiten oder mit deren
möglichkeiten ja auch verbreitung
verabredung zu straftaten getroffen
werden können also wie dieses auch
besonders intensiv diskutiert es geht
darum sauber aber auch im
pädokriminalität und manches mehr also
großes feld insgesamt wir wollen ein
paar punkte vorab aufnehmen schon mal in
unserem gespräch hier heute morgen nach
der wende bevor um neuen der bundestag
darüber diskutiert mit johanna aus der
fdp-fraktion wo sie digital politische
sprecherin erst guten morgen hin und die
akquise ist bei uns der stellvertretende
vorsitzende der spd fraktion auch ihnen
einen guten morgen
ich habe ziemlich viele themen
angerissen wir werden nur einen teil
davon erörtern können vielleicht aber
trotzdem erst mal allgemein täuscht der
eindruck oder ist diese koalition oder
ist auch dieses innenministerium bislang
von noch einiges schuldig geblieben im
vergleich zu dem was angekündigt worden
ist zu beginn der regierungszeit nein
ganz im gegenteil gerade der heutige
haushalt den wir für das
bundesinnenministerium beschließen ist
der höchste etat den das
bundesinnenministerium jemals in der
geschichte gehabt hat wir stärken die
bereiche cybersicherheit wir stärken die
bereiche bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenschutz wo wir die lehren
ziehen wollen gerade aus der schlimmen
flutkatastrophe im aartal zuletzt die
tornados die wir gesehen haben in
lippstadt und paderborn wo wir einfach
die großen bedrohungsszenarien auch
aufgrund der klimatischen veränderungen
letztendlich sehen aber auch die klaren
prioritäten im kampf gegen extremismus
insbesondere den rechtsextremismus sehen
der wie alle lage-einschätzung momentan
deutlich machen eine der größten
gefahren für die demokratie in unserem
land ist konkret ist noch nichts
verabschiedet
es ist verabschiedet dass wir gegen hass
und hetze verstärkt vorgehen wollen
gerade auch im internet wir haben ja wie
sie es ja auch angekündigt haben leider
fälle wo aus worten taten geworden sind
hier gehen wir ganz klar vor wir wollen
auch gleichzeitig im kampf gegen
extremismus dafür sorgen dass
verfassungsfeinde nicht im öffentlichen
dienst sind und wir wollen die mittel
für die demokratie um die demokratie zu
stärken auch mit einem demokratie
fördergesetz zeitnah auf den weg bringen
das sind schritte die gehen in die
richtige richtung um unsere demokratie
in unserem land zu stellen viele
vorhaben frau coach ist ihre sicht der
dinge es wurde viel angekündigt bis
jetzt noch gar nicht umgesetzt feser ist
eigentlich damit aufgefallen dass sie
eher vorschläge gemacht haben die die
fachwelt belächelt hat oder sich darüber
empört hat die centrotec becks zum
beispiel dass sie gesagt dass sie es für
hacks wenn wir digital angegriffen
werden durch cyber-angriffe dass wir
zurück hatten sollen dann hat die ganze
fachwelt auf gelacht dann ist die
schnell zurück gerudert damit ist die
innenministerin bisher aufgefallen
müssen sie vielleicht erläutern der
begriff weil ich vermute mal nicht alle
ihn verstehen und ich ziehe mich damals
gerade mit das ist wenn dir angegriffen
werden durch einen cyberangriff und so
infrastruktur dass wir die möglichkeit
haben sollen in deutschland dass wir
zurück hatten und zurück angreifen und
das ist alles gar nicht so einfach
möglich es ist eigentlich die dümmste
mögliche
die chance sich tatsächlich zu werden
anstatt dafür zu sorgen dass wir uns
wehren können dass wir defensive
abwehrmaßnahmen gegen cyber attacken
haben das hat die ganze fachwerkhäuser
erklärt und dementsprechend ist sie dann
auch zurückgerudert ja wieso ja das ist
nicht ganz wichtig denn wir haben die
klaren prioritäten im bereich cyber
sicherheit gesetzt jetzt ist es so heute
wird der etat für das
bundesinnenministerium verabschiedet
besetzen die klaren prioritäten für das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik wir haben mehr
personelle stärken die wir aufbauen
dieses bundesamt muss auch weiter
gestärkt werden und im bereich der cyber
abwehr aktiv und gut aufgestellt zu sein
das zeigen gerade die bedrohungslagen
die wir durch den russischen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine sehen wo
es immer mehr angriffe und
unsicherheiten letztendlich auch gibt
einige beispiele haben wir in den
vergangenen wochen gesehen und von daher
wir gehen in dem bereich voran aber
nochmal eine der größten bedrohungs
herausforderung ist auch der kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus gerade durch
parteikollegen wie hyballa und andere
innerhalb der afd und das gerade hierzu
jetzt nichts gesagt worden ist das
überrascht mich jetzt nicht jetzt mal
die gelegenheit geben auch dazu noch ein
zwei sätze zu sagen jaja so zuerst will
ich ganz gerne sagen wenn sie sagen dass
bisher soll gestärkt werden ich war
schon mal vor wenn es nicht mehr in
abhängigkeit vom innenministerium stehen
würde damit wir richtig für die
sicherheit in deutschland seien sorgen
colombo das war eine selbstständig eine
eigenständige behörde nicht abhängig vom
innenministerium das innenministerium
ist natürlich immer darauf bedacht die
handtücher zu halten zu sagen wir
brauchen irgendwie hinter türen damit
was überwachen können und das bsi ist
für unsere sicherheit für unser cyber
sicherheit zuständig und und die sind
natürlich dann interessiert gewisse
lücken zu schließen und all das was dem
ministerium eigentlich widerspricht und
das passt nicht zusammen deswegen muss
das psi tatsächlich selbstständig
gestellt hatte und ja also wieso herr
kubala plötzlich ein rechtsextremist
sein soll das müssen wir erst mal
erklären aber er hat glaube ich auch
ihren kollegen höcker erwähnt der herr
wieso hat er den kontext hat er aber
also ich habe mir jetzt mal die zahlen
angeguckt auch in vorbereitung auf
dieses interview und er hat die
bundesanwaltschaft im letzten jahr
ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet 210
gegen islamismus 10 gegen
linksextremismus und 5 gegen
rechtsextremismus also dieser aufgebaute
das größte bedrohung in deutschland ist
der rechtsextremismus das geben die
zahlen einfach nicht her dann bleiben
wir doch noch mal bei dem thema
eigentlich ganz was anderes vor an
dieser stelle aber irgendwie weil ich
jetzt einfach noch mal die seite zu
hören wollte weil sie ja eben auch
gesagt haben wir wie sie dass das der
größte gefahrenbereich sei wenn ich
jetzt bin ich diese wenn man diese
zahlen hört klingt es ja so als sei das
nicht so nein da muss man ganz klar
widersprechen und wir haben die
polizeiliche kriminalstatistik letztens
erst vorgelegt bekommen wir haben gerade
den lagebericht extremismus vorgelegt
bekommen wo ganz klar deutlich wird dass
die größte gefahr für diese demokratie
vom rechtsextremismus ausgeht von
militanten rechtsextremismus ausgeht wir
haben in den vergangenen jahren immer
wieder anschläge im bereich des rechts
terrorismus auch gehabt und das
sozusagen jetzt hier zu verharmlosen ich
sicherlich an den engen verknüpfungen
der afg in dieses milieu
die zahlen sind für alle öffentlich
nachlesbar ich kann ihnen merkt dem
bericht auch gerne zur verfügung stellt
ein bisschen sacharbeit ja ganz gut wenn
man sich dann noch weiter informiert
dass man nicht deswegen müssten sie
eigentlich die zahlen parat haben wenn
sie sowas behalten ich habe hier welche
20 21 habe ich schon gesagt 55.000
straftaten die polizei als politisch
motivierte gelten ein zuwachs bei
gewalttaten von 16 prozent soviel
rechtsextremistisch motivierte
straftaten ich glaube auch wie bisher
circa 22.000 die judenfeindliche
straftaten plus 29 prozent einen
höchststand also das sind die
offiziellen zahlen auf die ich
zugegriffen habe gestern bei der
vorwäsche jetzt müssen sie gucken was
fällt hinunter politische rechte
straftaten wenn ein syrischer
einwanderer ein hakenkreuz an eine wand
malt dann fällt das politische rechts
und dann überlegen wir uns mal wie sowie
diesen zahlen zustande kommt wir wissen
alle dass das gewollt ist dass diese
zahlen so hoch sind dann müsste man viel
mehr differenzieren und wenn es angriffe
auf die jüdischen mitbürger bei uns in
deutschland gibt dann müssen sie die
täter auch anschauen die kommen meistens
aus dem islamischen bereich und auch das
wird er verschleiert feldmann diese
wahrheit nicht tragen möchten wie sie ja
also jetzt ein beispiel heranzuziehen
ein syrischer einwanderer der ein
hakenkreuz auf die auf die wand merkt
man muss jetzt mal ganz kurz feststellen
dass da doch die argumentationsgrundlage
sehr schwach ist wir können das sehr
klar sagen der mord an walter lübke
hanau halle da sind die schweren
attentate passiert die rechts
terroristischen hintergrund haben und
sich hierhin zu stellen und das zu
verharmlosen und hier keine klare linie
zu haben sondern eine linie zu vertreten
die von einem haken dann auch noch einen
parteikollegen von ihnen immer wieder
instrumentalisiert wird ausgenutzt wird
das ist schon muss ich sagen wirklich
erschreckend heute morgen er wirft sie
einmal noch was dazu sagen dann wechseln
wir das thema also das ist eigentlich
gar nicht wert ich weiß nicht wie man in
höckel mit dem rechtsextremismus und
diesen taten in verbindung bringen kann
es tut mir leid von daher ist das gar
nicht wert auf zu anbringen lassen wir
das an dieser stelle hier so stehen er
werden der verfassungsschutz in diesem
kontext nicht die eu kommission hat
einen plan eine pflicht zu erlassen für
im unter internet unternehmen wie google
facebook und andere ihre seiten nach
missbrauchs- fotos und videos zu
durchsuchen dieser plan ist in der
diskussion die bundesinnenministerium
hat sich verhalten positiv geäußert zu
dem ganzen vorgang auch wenn sie sagt
prävention und strafverfolgung seien
noch ein bisschen wichtiger wie ist die
position der bundestagsfraktion dazu
haben die vorschläge aus der eu
kommission zur kenntnis genommen da ist
viel richtiges drin einiges muss man
sich aber auch noch genau anschauen weil
gerade vor dem hintergrund müsste man
muss man wissen wir warten noch auf eine
entscheidung des europäischen
gerichtshofs zur vorratsdatenspeicherung
wir haben einige hinweise des ogh
bekommen dass das sogenannte quick
freeze verfahren zulässig ist oder auch
die speicherung von daten gerade bei
schwersten straftaten von daher wir
schauen da sehr genau hin und sind jetzt
in enger abstimmung um auch die
richtigen und wichtigen sachen die wir
brauchen im kampf gegen den ausufernden
formen des sexuellen missbrauchs von
kindern das wäre gerade in den letzten
tagen wieder die fälle gesehen haben
hier auch weiter voran zu kommen sie
sprechen den fall in wermelskirchen an
das ganze thema firmiert frau kutter
unter dem begriff chat kontrolle in der
zeit habe ich dazu gelesen ein bisschen
irreführender begriff sagen die weil er
suggeriert dass jegliche privatsphäre
durchforstet wörter ziel ist laut der eu
allerdings ein möglichst geringer
eingriff in eben diesem bereich sie
lehnen das ganze in bausch und bogen ab
warum was ist falsch daran missbrauch zu
verhindern oder zumindest ist die
verbreitung von missbrauchs fotos oder
videos zu verhindern da dann ist erstmal
gar nichts falsch aber das leben nicht
nur ich ab das liegt die gesamte
fachwelt ab denn das fühlt sich
tatsächlich zu unterschiedlichen
argumenten ja aber das führt tatsächlich
zur massenüberwachung und es wundert
mich ein bisschen und es erschreckt mich
ein bisschen dass die spd davon nicht
direkt abstand nimmt auch noch fräser
nicht aber die sec davon abstand
genommen hat geht es auch um
verschlüsselungen hier geht es um die
privatsphäre der leute hier geht es
darum das unternehmen mit upload filter
mit allem was möglich ist die privaten
nachrichten alles was die user posten
durchleuchten und wenn sie dann ein foto
posten
oder verschicken von ihrem kind am stand
dann landet das eventuell bei
irgendwelchen ermittlungsbehörden das
geht so nicht was ist das höhere gut
private kommunikation oder schutz vor
blind für schutz von kindern das kann
man so überhaupt gar nicht gegenüber
stellt das ist eben das problem man
kommt mit dem begriff kinderpornografie
man bekommt mit diesen erschreckenden
dürfen wo jeder sagt natürlich wollen
wir dagegen vorgehen aber nicht alle
maßnahmen sind gerechtfertigt und einem
massen überwachten durch die hintertür
einzuführen und als als aussehen gesteht
zu sagen wir gehen die in
kinderpornografie vor das geht nicht das
ist gefährlich das ist ein ganz
gefährlicher wegen den dürfen wir nicht
beschreiten meerwiese was ist das höhere
gut gehörte kommunikation oder schutz
von kindern vor missbrauch ich habe dann
eine sehr klare priorität wenn ich mir
die fürchterlichen verbrechen an kindern
anschauen die ihr ganzes leben lang
darunter leiden dann müssen wir genau
hinschauen was ist rechtsstaatlich
möglich um diese täter zur rechenschaft
zu ziehen um diese schlimmen taten zu
verhindern man muss genau hinschauen was
wirkt das quick freeze verfahren kann
eine möglichkeit letztendlich sein
müssen wir vielleicht auch noch mal
entschuldigen ganz kurz wenigstens noch
einen halbsatz zu verwenden und darum
daten relativ schnell zu sichern für
einen bestimmten zeitraum wenn ich es
richtig in erinnerung habe genau wenn
anhaltspunkte ermittlungsansatz punkte
da sind das sozusagen daten ip-adressen
eingefroren werden damit die
ermittlungsbehörden die möglichkeit
haben darauf zuzugreifen und im bereich
von schwersten straftaten auch die
speicherung ip adressen ist ein
vorschlag den nancy faeser gerade
gemacht hat auch umzusetzen wie gesagt
meine klare priorität ist der schutz der
kinder hier müssen wir vorangehen hier
müssen wir auch noch mehr tun und dass
die afg schwierigkeiten mit der
veröffentlichung von chat protokollen
hat das haben wir ja gerade dass in der
vergangenheit gesehen aber die werden ja
auch so veröffentlicht speicherung ganz
kurzen wir haben das so erklären auch
nochmal der zuschauerin die nicht ganz
so tief drin sind die speicherung von
ip-adressen deshalb interessant weil die
auf einen bestimmten rechner von leben
aus irgendwas veröffentlicht worden ist
zurückweisen die aber relativ schnell
wechseln können auch unter so und
deswegen muss man die sicherheit damit
man das weiter nach verfolgt jetzt
würden sie
stellung beziehen digital ausschuss hat
ihr koalitionspartner die fdp damit dass
diese chat kontrolle so wie sie jetzt
geplant ist gegen den koalitionsvertrag
verstoßen und ich wäre dankbar und froh
wenn die spd das auf dem schirm hätte
was würden sie denn machen wenn
um diese fälle die sie ja offensichtlich
auch verurteilen irgendwie um sowas zu
verhindern einzudämmen zu verfolgen auch
die täter dingfest zu machen und alles
was dazugehört wenn dieser bereich der
versuch der strafverfolgung ausfällt was
sind ihre alternativvorschläge das ist
das was ich generell sagen bei
straftaten im internet das was was
analog verboten ist es im internet
verboten und wir müssen unsere justiz
und unser polizei in die lage versetzen
dass sie dem tatsächlich nachgehen kann
wir haben zu wenig personal wir haben zu
wenig punkte ausgebildetes personal da
müssen wir massiv aufstocken dass sie
sich auch im server umsichtig bewegen
können und dementsprechend auch richtig
ermitteln können das ist die aufgabe
unserer behörden und den müssen sie
nachkommen aber bitte nicht jeden bürger
unter generalverdacht stellen und seine
private nachrichten an der stelle
vermutlich mal sind sie ja durchaus
einig dass es da mehr personal braucht
wir um die fälle im ordnungsgemäß
nachzuverfolgen warum dann trotzdem noch
dieser zusätzliche weg weil wir
letztendlich auf der einen seite
natürlich personal möglichkeiten von
künstlicher intelligenz brauchen um
diese schiere anzahl an daten überhaupt
letztendlich auch her zu werden aber ich
habe im internet die herausforderung
dass die täter sozusagen sich verstecken
können nicht gefunden werden können den
möglichkeiten die das internet ihnen
momentan gibt nutzt und diese straftaten
zu begehen und da muss ich ganz deutlich
sagen wir müssen wir die möglichkeiten
die rechtsstaatlich zulässig sind nutzen
um diesen tätern die diese perfiden
taten begehen dingfest zu werden
handhabe zu werden und die kinder zu
schützen und das ist eine klare
priorität und da bin ich sehr eindeutig
und hab dann nicht so eine auffassung
für die kollegen im ziel wahrscheinlich
einig über die art und weise in sehr
unterschiedlicher auffassungen das haben
wir jetzt gerade auch noch mal gemerkt
wie so vielen dank dass ich heute morgen
bei uns gewesen sind auch ihnen frau
unter vielen dank allen diskussionen wie
gleich im plenum fortgesetzt wenn ich
vermute mal ein wirklich auch zu diesem
thema weiter zu den aktuell diskutierten
gehören vielen dank für heute morgen